Speaker 1: Speaking of dying of COVID. In today's
voicemail, we have an interesting
Speaker 2: question about that.
Speaker 1: Our voicemail number is two one
nine two David P.. You can call any time of
Speaker 2: day, really, any of
Speaker 1: you want to call it four a.m. Go
ahead and do it. Here's a caller asking, you know,
now that we know how sick Trump was of COVID?
What if Trump had died of COVID?
Speaker 6: Hey, David, I just had a
question. Want to get your insight on something?
So as we now know, Trump almost died of COVID
about a month before the election around.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he was very sick. I don't know
if he almost died, but he was very, very sick.
Speaker 6: Early October 2020,
I want to know what do you think would
have been the fallout from that, given
the rampant sea of conspiracy theories now? Do you
think that there would have been these countless
conspiracies about how the deep state
got him just before the election? And
do you think there would have been any sort of
violent protests or riots, anything like that?
I would love to get your insight.
Speaker 1: Thank all of the above all
of the above. I mean, listen, guys, if Trump
had died of COVID, it was it even a month,
three weeks before the presidential election?
Every conspiracy theory you can imagine and
ones you can't imagine would have been out there.
The obvious ones, of course, the Democrats killed
him. The deep state killed him. His political
opponents killed him. Dr. Fauci killed, you know,
all all, all of that stuff. But then there would
have been more. So like the Cuban people would
have had their own version, which probably
would have been like he was about to unleash
hell upon the pedophile ring that he was fighting.
And so it was actually the pedophiles who killed
him or targeted him with COVID. Or this
was a biological terror assassination. They
they deliberately injected him with, yes, COVID,
but also poison or anything you could imagine.
Would have been proposed if Donald Trump
had not survived COVID in October of 2020,
and hard to even imagine what would have happened
after that, I mean, I think just Biden would have
won, quite frankly. I think it would have been
pretty simple, but we don't know. We will never
know because it didn't ultimately happen. We have
a great bonus show for you today. Gavin Newsom in
California is doing something very interesting.
He is using or attempting to use the exact same
Speaker 2: framework from the
Speaker 1: Texas abortion ban
to ban assault weapons in California.
It's a very wild political switcheroo,
which just might work. We're going to talk about
it on the bonus show. Also, insulin prices a big
sort of battle line when it comes to prescription
prices, insulin prices may change dramatically
if Democrats get their way. We'll explain how it
relates to build back better. And I'm also going
to talk about Rand Paul's just completely
Speaker 2: pathetic,
Speaker 1: hypocritical, hypocritical relief
begging. You may remember many times in the past.
There's a natural disaster. There's a proposal
to get money to the area and Rand Paul
Speaker 2: votes against it
Speaker 1: now that a natural disaster
has affected Kentucky, these tragic hurricane of
tornadoes rather that hit Kentucky and parts of
Tennessee, I believe, over the weekend. Now
Rand Paul is saying, if Joe Biden doesn't
Speaker 2: get us all the money right away
Speaker 1: for everything,
then he's doing a very bad thing. What happened,
rand? I thought you didn't want money for these
things, and they're all hypocrites on this.
Ted Cruz has been. I think James Inhofe,
there's a whole bunch of them. So we're going
to talk about that. On today's bonus show,
remember that tomorrow, Tuesday, December 14th
at six p.m. is the final David Pakman Show Viewer
Town Hall of the Year. I look forward to seeing
you there. And on today's bonus show, which you
can sign up for and get instant access to
Unidentified: join Tottenham, the CNN.